another delayed court appearance for 27
year old terrell rhodes
he is accused of murdering his
girlfriend's two-year-old son
prosecutors say rhodes confessed to
killing amari nicholson
then hiding his body for days he claimed
the child had been taken by an
unknown family member bianca holman is
live this afternoon at the clark county
detention center with the latest in the
case bianca
rhodes is being held here at the jail
with no bail
he was supposed to appear in court today
and friday both times he was a no-show
and we're told that he is being held in
quarantine and that's
the reason why he has not been in a
courtroom rhodes is charged with open
murder
and was supposed to be in court today on
that case he's also charged with
resisting arrest and assault
on a protected person he's scheduled for
an appearance tuesday on those charges
amari's nicholson's father and his
family they showed up to the courthouse
today
they tell me they're still grieving the
loss of their son
nephew and loved one
we tried in the past to make amari a
part of our family
and we for some reason were denied that
opportunity
and we feel that amari spoke to us
throughout this whole process
we're here because we still need closure
we still want to make sure that there is
justice for
mari we're all we're coming from all
over the country
just to show him that amari had options
he had people that cared about him and
he did not have to go this way
now the family says funeral arrangements
have not been said at this time they
want to say thank you to the vegas
community for their unwavering support
so they plan to meet this afternoon
there will be a balloon release in an
hour at the seagull suites bianca holman
8 news now